et nous sommes avec jean baptiste eyraud
porte parole du dal
le droit au logement bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous la fondation abbé
pierre a donc une nouvelle fois dénoncé
hier des loyers trop élevés des prix
boosté par manque de logement en général
rien ne change
selon vous la situation se dégrade c'est
le constat statistique fait la fondation
abbé pierre
puisqu'on a toujours plus de mal logés
de sans abri toujours plus de jugements
d'expulsion et des loyers qui augmentent
des prix de l'immobilier qui continuent
à flamber et donc une crise du logement
qui s'installe de manière durable des
qui a tendance à progresser
donc là vraiment
il s'agit de modifier fondamentalement
les politiques du logement qui
aujourd'hui sont orientés plutôt vers de
soutien ce qu'on pourrait qualifier au
logement cher et la cherté du logement
des locataires en savent quelque chose
mais les accédants à la propriété aussi
qui voit la part de leur revenu
augmenter et et d'un autre côté et bien
le gouvernement aussi mènent des
politiques qui durcissent les conditions
de logement des classes populaires des
ménages modestes puisque il fait des
économies considérables près de 4
milliards d'euros sur les apl en année
pleine c'est-à-dire 2010 9,4 milliards
d'euros 2018 un peu moins mais oui et
d'année en année les économies qui sont
faites par le gouvernement sur le dos
des plus précaires augmente la même
façon que les
za la construction de logements sociaux
sont en baisse aussi
donc d'un côté baissé entre 2016 et 2018
oui c'est ça a baissé
comme je voulais 10 2 4 milliards
d'euros alors que les loyers augmentent
que les ménages des revenus modestes
sont plutôt en baisse
les économies sont faites aussi sur des
aides sur des minima sociaux tout ça
donc
et puis les salaires donc on a vraiment
tous des éléments seront réunis pour
malheureusement pour la crise s'aggrave
et pourtant le ministre chargé de la
ville et du jeu et du logement je viens
de normandie a vanté hier les bons
résultats du plan un logement d'abord
lancé en 2010 750 et 1000 personnes sont
sorties de la rue ou de l'hébergement
d'urgence en deux ans grâce à cette
action selon ministre comment vous
réagissez à ces propos j'ai un peu
dubitatif un jeu d'abord on voit ça d'un
petit peu plus près nous ce qu'on
constate c'est que il ya toujours plus
de sans abri et au fond on va pas dire
que c'est la faute des migrants puisque
on a connu des périodes beaucoup plus de
migrants en france on a réussi à les
loger
non c'est que aujourd'hui n'y a pas
volonté de loger les ménages modestes y
compris les migrants et pas
exclusivement bien sûr on pense à tous
ceux qui sont qui sont locataires ou qui
arrivent sur le marché du logement qui
commencent à travailler qui arrive pas à
se loger et au fond ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est vraiment une
aggravation de la crise qui se traduit
par une augmentation des profits et les
richesses extraite du logement les
groupes financiers internationaux
aujourd'hui interviennent sur le marché
immobilier français dans les métropoles
achètent parce qu'ils ont énormément
d'argent donc hachette qui gère l'argent
des riches donc ils achètent des
immeubles en espérant évidemment une
plus value qu'ils obtiennent puisque les
prix de l'immobilier continuent à
augmenter
donc là on a à la fois soul et ce
problème là cette pression spéculative
et qui est soutenu aussi par les
politiques d'urbanisme
on est à quelques mois à quelques
semaines des élections municipales il
faut quand même rappeler que
les municipalités dans l'ensemble même
des politiques d'urbanisme qui entraîne
qui vise à chasser ou qui entraîne si
vous voulez le départ des ménages les
plus pauvres
en témoigne d'ailleurs des politiques
anti sdf qui sont mises en place ou bien
les politiques de renouvellement urbain
qui consiste à détruire des immeubles
bon marché pas cher souvent des grands
logements pour les remplacer par du
logement pour des catégories sociales
plus aisés c'est là c'est la
gentrification où l'opération sociale
oui on est il ya un double mouvement et
ce mouvement là est encourage évidemment
par d'état le gouvernement qui tire
beaucoup d'argent d'eux qu'ils tirent
beaucoup de profit du logement cher
puisque on a à peu près 70 milliards de
recettes par an sur le logement qui vont
sur les pouvoirs publics alors que les
pouvoirs publics ne dépense que 40
milliards donc vous voyez c'est vraiment
une exploitation une surexploitation des
surette du droit à un logement enfin de
remise en question de la nécessité d'une
relation de la nécessité pour chacun
d'être loger décemment qui aujourd'hui
viol et d'ailleurs c'est dans la loi et
cette fois les violer constamment et le
gouvernement a annoncé un futur service
public de la rue au logement dans
l'esprit du samu social qu'est ce que
vous en attendez honnêtement je ne sais
pas ça fait
enfin nous ce qu'on voit c'est que on
reste dans la rue tous les jours on les
voit dans nos permanences
on appelle les sans abri appellent le
115 et restent dans la rue et s'ils sont
pris en charge ils ont remis au bout de
trois mois ils sont mis dans la rue le
28 mars le 31 mars va sonner à nouveau
la fermeture des places d'hébergement
hivernal
ainsi que le retour des expulsions
locatives ainsi qu'une nouvelle économie
d'ailleurs sur les apl
donc voilà c'est le 1er avril
malheureusement ça va être encore une
triste date pour les locataires les mal
logés tous les sans abri dans le pays
alors que par ailleurs on compte 3,1
millions de logements vacants et ça il
faut savoir qu'on en a jamais compté
autant dans notre pays un million de
plus depuis 10 ans c'est à dire aux
mesures que les prix de l'immobilier
flambent
le nombre de logements vacants augmente
donc à réellement un contexte spéculatif
merci beaucoup d'être un venu réagir sur
notre plafond mentionné jean termine
pour dire qu'il faut absolument
réquisitionné appliquer la loi de
réquisition il faut appliquer les lois
en france qui permettent de protéger des
bergers qui oblige l'état à héberger des
sans-abri et y compris si besoin par la
loi de réquisition
on a bien compris votre message jean
baptiste eyraud porte parole du dal
droit au logement